yay
hi ryan thanks for coming on the show
hey alan thanks for
the invitation
yes this is exciting
ready to talk about marxism and class
analysis
yes exactly
yeah this is very important i'm excited
to talk about this
some background that'll be helpful for
the audiences that
ryan and i go back like 15 years to
the early days of
high school actually in sioux falls
south dakota
and
[Music]
then ryan and i also passed some time
together in minneapolis
in minnesota and then also in san
francisco
and the bay area and so we've maintained
our friendship
over the last decade and a half and
we've also been exploring
different lenses of perception and
yes and in this case
this related
especially to meeting
basic needs for me this is where i'm
most interested
in this topic is as basic needs are met
people get to expand their lens of
perception
to incorporate more
self-actualization and self-realization
so both empowerment and enlightenment
and they get to do that based on
leaving the contracted
energy which is
feeling like their entire consciousness
is tied to economics
it tied to earning a wage tied to labor
and and so we're gonna talk about that
and
uh ryan has been for the last two
years involved in
the marxist leninist
from the angle especially a pharmacy
which is where we're also going to talk
about this as a pharmacist
and most recently also
um with the center for political
innovation building a vision for
socialism with
american characteristics so
and you guys may hear me call ryan
cotton as we
talk and ryan yeah
yeah and ryan you can i know that for
ryan it's funny calling me atlas
but call me atlas yeah okay
hello atlas
love it so all right cotton let's start
things off with
the journey and we have this really cool
doc
that ryan put together for us
where we will sort of be breaking down a
lot of
the the concepts in more detail
for you guys um and we have these great
visualizations
as well and and hopefully they'll
uh enable a visualization of the core
points that ryan is going to be sharing
with us so
i i find this intro to be really
interesting with pharmacy
because it's basically what everyone
knows
right everyone knows this they go in
to the doctor's office or any healthcare
pharmacy
and what happens immediately is they're
wondering
is the doctor or pharmacist incentives
are they perverse are they tied to the
company's
uh bottom line and profit or are they
actually
interested and invested in my health
and so that's a great intro into this so
let's uh let's have you kick it off
yeah thank you for that introduction
atlas um
so i'll just kind of introduce how i got
interested in marxism and like you said
it's only been two years for me i'm i'm
relatively new
to marxism um but i feel that i've put a
lot of work in to try to understand it
um and it's taken me a while to
to get to the positions i've come to um
so so working in retail pharmacy and
seeing countless
patients get burned by a health care
system that puts
profits before patients in pharmacy
school we were taught
a philosophy of care a philosophy of
care that always puts patients first
seeing my patients frustrated with
insurance policy
and drug costs i started working in the
health payer industry
where i quickly realized that there was
a fundamental misalignment
between the interests of my patients and
the financial interests in health care
so i became a pharmacist to fight for my
patients however i've
realized that fighting imperialism and
advocating socialism
seemed to be the only way to resolve the
contradictions in health care
so what what started as just as a
pharmacist
trying to serve my patients
turn into this long journey of
discovering
what was really holding our system back
from evolving and it's
it's capitalism
and so um since then since then i've
been reading
a lot of books i used to not really be a
reader but
i just got stacks and stacks of books
here
i got a huge bookshelf now i do a lot of
reading in my free time so
and um also currently
working with the center for political
innovation um
trying to develop our ideological
positions working with a group of
very devoted um committed
marxist leninists and 21st century
socialists
and um kind of the position we've taken
as an organization is
that our role as communists as marxists
as class conscious workers is to is to
educate
the masses and so for
historically the left has kind of been
stuck
in in this movement politics
without really an emphasis on going out
to the broad population
and so that's what we believe is is key
right now is
is fostering a vision for what america
could look like
as a socialist country and
and getting that out to the masses
so there's two core points there
that i really found
critical which was that
the notion that you have this
great incentive engine which in a sense
is
if you end up doing some sort of
profound innovation
capitalism will ensure that in many ways
that
you can get rewarded for this profound
innovation and for hard work which is
cool and it's important
and yet at the same time there's this
extractive essence simultaneously
that capitalism has promulgated and we
have to just be honest about
that where we're putting profits over
people and in that process people feel
like they're
literally having their energy and life
force sucked
out of them for somebody else to be able
to
gain another materialistic possession
and so we have to be completely honest
about that and we have to
also recognize that there are benefits
to
and you'll probably hear me reference um
collectivism and merging collectivism
with
individualism and i'll probably be
calling it that where
whereas you could also view it as like
capitalism and socialism or communism
but i do like collectivism and
individualism and merging those two
together like the best of both
together into whatever the next
generation future architecture is which
is what we'll
also be talking about and then
the other thing that i like that you
mentioned was this is what the
redesigning is
of the social contract which puts people
first
is that when you sort of gain awareness
of the unity of all existence
and being when you actually see
everyone else as yourself
when you sort of get to that high level
of consciousness where you begin seeing
everyone else
as yourself all as that one intelligence
which is this universe at play when you
begin
seeing that you have no other interest
but to ensure like be in service to
ensuring that people's basic needs are
met
and to be ensure and to ensure that
people
have fractional ownership in
the next generation architectures
and that we get to things like the venus
project or
star trek as quickly and
efficiently as as possible we have these
big bright north stars
and so this is where decentralization
blockchain
cryptocurrency biomimicking the
fungal networks and the internet
and these different things that we've
seen as a biological archetype
which we'll we'll probably talk about
more as as we go through the show but i
i really am i'm i really enjoy that
first
lens which is everyone feels that so
relatably
is healthcare and is the doctor
the pharmacist is the healthcare system
actually having my
interests first or is it putting the
profits
first and this is also felt obviously
with
other industries like food is is this
food
actually putting my health first or is
this food putting
their addictive
substances first so that i come back
and continue purchasing the food to
increase the bottom line of the food
company
so people are feeling this more and more
and they feel very weird about
how profit is being put first over
people
exactly yeah food isn't produced to feed
people
it's produced so a capitalist can sell
it and make a profit
health care is the same way it's it's
not
there to heal people it's it's there to
make people who've it's people it's
there to
make profits and
it initially was
put in place as uh because there was
demand for it
um
by the by the working class and so most
of the gains we've made as a society
have been
advocated by the working class rising up
and demanding it
and the point you made about technology
is really interesting
because that's a really essential part
of marxism is that
technology really drives the economy
forward
and what's happened with capitalism is
technology or
in machines and robots they're
they're called labor-saving devices and
that they've
they now compete with the workers and
that doesn't mean that technology is bad
but it means that
that the capitalists are using
technology to
create an unemployed class
and
and um yeah workers aren't workers
haven't benefited from the technology
the massive
technology that that has happened in the
past few decades
the workers haven't seen one one penny
of it it's it's gone
directly up to the capitalists and
they're appropriating more and more
today than they ever have
a wealth inequality is pretty insane
right now it's
it's historic levels and uh
technology should be serving serving
everyone not just
a few
so i love i love what you just said
there
i'll provide some um additional
um data which is that
um the current
statistics for um
wealth is that there are
2 200 billionaires on the planet
and there are 225 000 ultra high net
worth
individuals and families which ultra
high net worth is 30 million
plus in assets and so
um in a sense if you looked at this like
the
uh like the fungal networks and how they
relate to the
like the mother trees um in the
forest is that the mother trees that are
extracting
additional co2
and then converting that in
photosynthesis
are serving the smaller trees
and fungi
sugars with the photosynthetic process
and so they're providing
as the mother tree the additional
resources
to the smaller seedlings and smaller
trees
and fungi and there's a two-way resource
exchange because the fungi are also
taking out
nitrogen phosphorus potassium water and
they're giving it to the
other trees and mother trees as well so
it's not a one-way it's two-way
but so now what we're looking at is the
question would be
what's going on with the hyper
wealthy where out of every new
dollar that is generated and i think
this
this is also a very important
visualization
is the uh
this this website is really helpful um
for people
what the [ __ ] happened in 1971 wtf
happened in 1971.com
and what you see is that you have
this median mail income
in around 1971 that flatlined
right here meanwhile real gdp
continued to skyrocket and so now you
have
this real gdp that's continuing to
skyrocket
which is mostly the
highest uh wealthiest people that are
taking the profits of this real gdp
skyrocketing
meanwhile median male income as you know
with all of your friends um
they're wondering the friends that are
in the vast majority of people
they're all wondering why am i not
seeing an increase in my purchasing
power
and so now this is what um this is a
really useful visualization
yeah that's that's so interesting you
point to that year 19
1971 because i was going to talk about
that it's in my
our document here um and what what
happened from the marxist perspective
that year um where is it ryan
in the dark it's under the um what i
what happened after world war ii
right here yeah and the rise of
neoliberalism
okay cool yeah let's do that then
um well before we get all the way there
i'd like to cover a few more things
let's do it this part up here right yeah
so
okay so you were talking about our unity
and realizing our our unity
and so marxists see that we're united as
a class
and what what class is our our
relationships to production so most of
us are workers
we we have to work for a living that's
how we
obtain our mean subs substance um
that's how we feed ourselves house
ourselves all that
um the ruling class or the capitalists
or the bourgeoisie
they live off the work of others so they
don't actually produce anything
they're living off the work that the
workers have produced
and so and so to understand class we
have to step back a little bit um
understand dialectical materialism
which is the philosophy of marxism
and so dialectical materialism is
opposed to idealism
whereas dialectical materialism believes
that
our material reality
forms our consciousness whereas idealism
is more utopian and it believes that our
consciousness
determines our material reality
and historical materialism is just
applying
dialectical materialism to history and
so this is
the first major contribution that marx
made
and so in the the communist manifesto
here
it starts out on the first page he says
the history of all
hitherto existing society is the history
of class
troubles so what does that really mean
well all throughout history there's
always been
there's always been a division between a
ruling class and a subordinate class
except from the very beginning where we
where marx called it primitive communism
and this is a classless society
you can think of hunting and gathering
or um i think you shared with me a few
years ago this ubuntu
society in africa yeah which was pretty
interesting and
so they're classless society they
they're
uh there there's uh
there isn't exploitation there isn't a
ruling class and an underclass that's
working for the ruling class
um they kind of all work together but um
as technology
progressed um with the agricultural
revolution
um hunting and gathering became
inefficient
and so we saw the first major
socio-economic order which was slavery
and so some major examples to think
about what slavery
looked like was rome um ancient greece
ancient egypt and so in slavery
we had the ruling class which was the
masters and the underclass
was the slaves and so eventually
this system um
there so there's these contradictions
right um
and so the contradictions
got to cut too intense and there had to
be
they had to become resolved and when
they
become resolved we get a new system so
um
it became inefficient and what we needed
was
was feudalism so in in feudalism
um the lords owned the land
and uh served they hired serfs to work
on the land so the serfs worked
half half their half their half their
day's work went to
paying the lords off and the other half
went to
serving their family or whatever um so
feudalism was mostly in europe and it
was the kings and the queens and
eventually we know that that fell in the
french revolution
and uh gave rise to capitalism
and so in capitalism um it wasn't an
agrarian society like feudalism
we we now had machines industrial
industrialization
which gave rise to the capitalist class
which we've talked about live off the
work of others and then the workers
and so now the ruling class isn't it's
not kings and queens anymore it's now
this
broader broader group of capitalists
and when we think of capitalists we have
to be specific in who we're talking
about this is the one percent
this is the global elite this isn't your
your restaurant owner or um
small business owner um so we're not
we're not against
it it's the person that owns the land on
that entire block that is then renting
the buildings out to the business owners
exactly and land is a very important
theme in this because
in feudalism the kings and the lords
owned all the land
and so that was basically just
transferred to the capitalists and now
the capitalists on the land
um and so socialism what that is is it
kind of flips those that class relation
on its head
and so now the workers are the ruling
class
or the proletariat and the capitalists
the bourgeoisie
are now subordinate to the to the
working working class
um so what i was saying about um
small business owners and restaurant
owners this
is they have a better they might have a
better
standard of life standard of living
so marx categorized them as the petty
bourgeoisie
and so they're not the big bourgeoisie
the capitalists
but they do they do benefit from the
system and they
they kind of go either way depending on
either way
in um supporting capitalists or workers
kind of depending on
the historical um situation
and which side serves their interests
during that time
there's also another group called the
lump and proletariat
which is the criminal class the drug
dealers burglars and prostitution
um pimps and all that and so they're
both of these both of these groups you
can just consider them
part of the working class still because
they're the 99
they're not part of this one percent
that owns the land and owns the means of
production
and and only serve themselves
okay so let's play with this for a
little bit
um as we continue going through this
because
this is a this is a great um beginning
breakdown for us
so one thing that you mentioned
that immediately got um
a big going was that
the relationship between
idealism or focusing on one's own
inner subjective conscious experience
and the relationship between the
external materialistic
architectures is very profound and
important
and the two are ultimately one but it's
nice to also
split them into two to understand them
and
so in this case both your own
individual sovereign conscious
experience
and the way that you can have deep
amounts of equanimity
with whatever is arising in perception
and sensation is very important but
simultaneously
the planetary architectures themselves
that enable you to be equanimous and
peaceful
are very important because if you're
having a massive
war or if you're having massive
inequality
if you're not having your basic needs
being met in your
materialistic existence then
you're going to that's profoundly going
to influence your ability
to be peaceful and happy and prosperous
and flourishing
and so we have to merge those two things
together
um as we awaken our and
and make our self-actualization and
self-realization
while we also enable these architectures
that i like how you brought up the
the essence of of land land was such a
big one because it basically was
the first monkeys that evolved
and said that i'm going to have i'm
going to own this piece of land and
people were like what the [ __ ] do you
mean you're going to own
this land this is we're we're the
natural this is the dao
this is the natural flow of existence
and you're going to just put
a couple of stakes in the ground and say
that i'm going to shoot you
if you walk on this land and then from
there everything dr
so super drastically changed because
then
you have like you described you have
people that are
in this slave or surf or worker class
and then you have the people that are in
the master the lord or the capitalistic
class
and it's really important to understand
that and to understand how to
um transition us slowly uh
and rapidly at the same time into where
you have
more fractional ownership where you have
more decentralization where you have
more maximizing prosperity for everyone
um simultaneously i think that that was
a great insight that
that we were going through together as
is recognizing the merging of idealism
and materialism
and recognizing the decentralization of
land ownership
and also of ownership of assets in
general
there's so few people that have
ownership of stocks
is another one and how can you make
yeah fractional ownership of stocks
more common where somebody with five
bucks or ten bucks
can own a little small portion of these
next generation companies
and how can then they get paid dividends
for that process more easily to where
it's not some massive conglomerate
um centralized entity that is managing
everything
but rather it's a more decentralized
frictionless process for people to
become fraction
fractional owners
yeah so i think the material reality
materialist perspective
and the i the um
idealist perspective of consciousness
well consciousness and material reality
they're they're in a dialectic and so
they're working
together and and they will form a unity
um and that's what dialectics
teaches is that we see we see the
problems in this world
as as opposing forces and eventually
they will meet and create something new
and so yeah land is land is a major
major contradiction that we just live
with
we accept that that there's people that
own the majority of the land i was just
looking at this this graphic that showed
um
bill gates and how much land he owns all
over the us it's
he owns like a major portion of land in
over half the states
um and so yeah there's been this
transformation as well within capitalism
um from more of an industrial base
to more of a financial base so we can
talk about that a little more later too
um but yeah so these
these contradictions in society
they they come together and they form
the new
the new system and so that's what we've
seen is this
these classes the history the history of
class struggle
these classes are antagonistic to each
other
they come together in a conflict a
revolution
and we we see a new system emerge and so
history is the history of class
struggles
because each of these systems as marx
recognized
each of them had has this class conflict
between a ruling class and the
subordinate class that conflict
eventually
comes together there's an explosion a
revolution or something
and we see the new system
interesting yep
which is basically what's happening
right now again is people feeling like
they are their basic needs aren't being
met they don't have any inclusive
stakeholding
in the uh real gdp continuing to
skyrocket
meanwhile their purchasing power is
flatlining
and there's more and more people that
are like we want decentralization
now we want fractional ownership now we
want
um our basic needs met now we want this
now um and we need to architect this now
and we need the
help of billionaires and high net worth
people to awaken
to helping see the whole planet as
the brothers and sisters as their family
in maximizing our collective potential
i can uh do you want to move down to the
graphic those two pictures
yes so another this is another important
subject to understand
relating to historical materialism and
dialectical materialism is
this idea of the superstructure so
the superstructure there's kind of two
layers to society
so on the bottom that that red half
circle
or that blue box that's the economic
base
and so when we think of capitalism
feudalism and slavery
it's not just an economic system it's an
entire social order
and it's based on the material
the material base and so in feudalism we
had an agrarian society
um and and that changed with factories
and industry
and and that's that's uh the basis of
capitalism and so
the top part is the ideology
and so that's how we think and act um
and
things that fall into that category our
art
culture religion philosophy law
healthcare
politics science education all those
things
and so when we think about
a capitalist society there's always its
corresponding ideology which today is is
liberalism liberalism is the ideology of
capitalism
and they shape each other and so
capitalism
um shapes how we think and act our
ideology
and that actually goes back down and
influences
the economic system so they're always in
in this conflict
this is so important this visual is so
important
in in order in order for you to
be able to expand your consciousness for
you to
um awaken to your highest potential and
possibility
you need your basic needs to be met and
you
also need to be a fractional owner in
the success of our species
it has to happen the the consciousness
and materialism
are ultimately one and they're in
dialectic and
you have to have your basic needs be met
and you have to have
fractional ownership in the planet's
success um for you to be able to achieve
your highest potential otherwise you're
going to get stuck
in a perpetual cycle of trying to meet
your basic needs and you're never going
to be able to explore your highest
potential
and so this is what this is such a good
way to
to visualize what is is going on between
um awakening and um
physicalism or architectures it's like
you have two things you have awakening
and you have architectures you have to
have them both
playing together at the same time so we
really need to hone in
on external architectures to enable
awakening as well
it's great and so
i think one of the problems in in the
west in american society
is we're we've had an ideology pushed
and imposed upon us and so this ideology
that that we live in and so we can see
if we look at our institutions
um like the the military institutions
how
how how that's so antagonistic to the
workers
and to humans um our education system
doesn't work in in the capital society
at least today
um all these systems are kind of just
breaking down right now and they
and they they they seem like they're
breaking down because
they're antagonistic to the worker
because they're not they're not the
workers ideology they're the capitalist
ideology
um
and so the alternative to capitalist
ideology liberalism is marxism
and so that's what marxism is it's an
ideology it's a way of thinking it's a
way of
analyzing the world it's a tool to see
it's a tool we can use to better
understand the problems in the world
and so what socialism aims to do
one of the definitions of socialism is
is that it's the antici antithesis of
capitalism so it's
it's seeking to resolve many of the
contradictions
that capitalism has
has uh brought about like the land
contradiction that's a that's a major
contradiction the fact that we have to
live with a state
a state that that
taxes us and uh goes to war
and taxes us for the horse um
yeah that our the state isn't
particularly to anyone's liking but it
um we can talk about more this more but
it
what one of the things lenin articulated
is he
he advanced the theory of marxism in a
few ways but one of the ways is
understanding the state
as a tool of class oppression so in a
capitalist society
they utilize the state as an institution
to serve their needs
to serve their interests to serve
profits
and in a socialist society they use the
state in a different way to serve
to serve public need
and so you had asked about class
consciousness specifically and i had to
explain kind of all those things
to get there excellent
but being class conscious is simply just
realizing that you're
a worker in this class struggle and you
realize that there's a historical
progression of society so you
you're realizing your historical mission
as a worker
to to to play a role in the transition
from capitalism
to the to socialism and the higher
stages of socialism
and it's really this
process um it's realizing that
it's realizing a greater good really
it's realizing that you have an
obligation
as a as a class conscious worker you're
not just a worker you're someone who's
who's actually realized this important
fact of history
and that you have an obligation a duty
and a mission
to to do something about it like
imperial imperialism and these
wars we have a duty to fight against
that
that's [ __ ] we don't want to be a
part of that we we don't
we don't we don't advocate and support
the wars
that's the ruling class who's pushed
that upon us and manufactured consent to
to get us to buy into these wars
and so what we've seen today with the
bernie and trump movement
is that they're they
talked a lot again a lot about being
anti-war and being anti-establishment
the establishment today
is the neoliberals um
and and they're the ones in control have
been in control
um and so what they've really
represented
was something that wasn't class
conscious
but they they understand where they know
that there's something really wrong at
the core of our society
and so they are pushing back against the
establishment
and both have different solutions class
unconscious solutions um but that's the
role of
the communists of the of the class
conscious worker
is to push these movements forward to
educate them and help them realize the
vision
and help understand that the problems
they're seeing are actually
contradictions within capitalism that
could be resolved
wow so class consciousness is this
transformation at least what i've what
have i
what i've experienced the past few years
is going from just a worker
to a class conscious worker or what we
call a proletariat
this process is also called
proletarianization
interesting once you become this class
conscious worker
you could also call yourself a communist
because that's
and the communist is a weird word
because it has a lot of
weird definitions but another another
definition that marx uses
is that communism is for us
not a state of affairs which is to be
established
and ideal to which reality will have to
adjust itself
we call communism the real movement
which abolishes the present state of
things
the present state of things is
neoliberalism it's capitalism and decay
imperialism or what lenin calls the
highest stage of capitalism
the present state of things is not good
we want we want to change that will
benefit the public
and there is a movement already here in
america there's an objective
communist movement here today and that's
what i think bernie and trump represent
and no one wants to call i mean you
you'd be
you'd be laughed out of the room calling
either of them a communist but what they
what their movements represent is
possibly something communist their
anti-war
anti-establishment against the
neoliberal order that's been in charge
and the people the people in these
movements understand something they know
that that there's something wrong at the
core
um one of my uh i have a
a really good quote from this book by
nelson pirie
he talks a lot about the role of the
vanguard or the communists
and what they should be doing this book
here
and he he has a quote that the future is
up to us
yeah the future is up to us and
yeah there's a cool uh cover on there
but uh he says that the role of the
vanguard or or the class conscious
worker
is to help people understand what they
already know
and so i think we've realized that in
our
in our in our work at the center for
political innovation
and realizing our role as educators in
fostering a vision for a better america
yep yep and we'll be
covering this in uh in more detail
as well um in a little bit on the show
so one thing
that you continuously
reference which i think is is so
beautiful
is that um
and this is sort of the angle that i've
been so pumped about taking this as well
is that
um you
you when you sort of get out of um what
has been
a habitual pattern
of just running a script of
going and working um
and then paying bills like without
having a
level of metacognition or awareness
of what you're doing like awareness of
your thinking
process of why am i going to work
these 40 hours to earn the money to pay
the rent and the food
what what kind of new architectures can
i have to increase my freedom
um to increase my awakened states of
consciousness this type of thing for
myself my family my community all this
and i like i like how you talked about
this like a
shift the proletarianization right
yeah yeah i like how you talk about it
like a shift in consciousness because it
really is
it's like um it's like gaining a level
of metacognition
about what you're doing and about how to
um enable your own deeper
freedom and awakening and also your
the planetary architectures that then
feed
back on um elevating consciousness
and on increasing fractional ownership
and everybody getting shares of the pie
and
us having like a big planetary birthday
party every day
and in order to get there yeah in order
to get there we have to sort of awaken
from the existing architectures that are
not
serving us and so yeah
and nobody wants to pay um a
a trillion dollars a year for a military
industrial complex
um and it's like something ridiculous
like
600 billion dollars a year for that and
then 60 billion dollars a year for
education
and nikola tesla was pointing at this as
well is that you have to flip
those numbers around you have to be
putting in a trillion dollars a year
into your education and be only putting
in whatever a couple
tens of billions into just like military
research
stuff that doesn't even have to do with
war but it has more to do with
things like figuring out unity
generators
figuring out fusion technology figuring
out
clean renewable energies and whatnot and
having engineers and military be focused
around that and not
on imperialism um and you're right
there's a huge
uprising that's happened in um politics
where the average joe whether it's on
the left or the right politically in the
u.s
is awakening to um what the [ __ ] i want
a share
in the success of this country i want to
share in the success of what i do every
day
like i deserve a fractional ownership in
the company that i work for
every day why do i as an employee that's
that's driving for uber not get
a small amount of uber ownership in
the in tokens that then
i've been driving for for five years
that i deserve
a share of the token ownership and not
just a paycheck
but also a share in the company's
success on the stock market
as well and so there's all these
different ways to view
how to increase fractional ownership
and to make the transition towards um
a more decentralized ownership of
planetary success
so cool stuff and and this is really
important because it locks your
consciousness because ryan's
ryan's right this is similar to myself
and so many others is that
you feel like your consciousness is
locked in the existing scripts that are
inhibiting your freedom
and the only way to liberate your
consciousness
is to become metacognized around
your processes and then also to inspire
more people to reflect on how to
architect
a more abundant prosperous future
yeah and there's a lot of forces holding
us back from becoming class conscious
um i'll talk about some of those in a
bit
but one of them is our already we've
talked about is ideology
and that liberalism
and the theology the ideology
of the ruling class is extremely
antagonistic
to us as workers um
and marx has this term called alienation
which is pretty interesting um so
in the past is that in here no i didn't
write it
okay okay alienation let's talk about it
because we were talking about the
individual
and how so so
so alienation when we go back um
in understanding our relationships to
production maybe in the past
we consider like a shoemaker
they would make a shoe and they would
spend a lot of hard work in producing
this shoe
and then they would sell it to their
friend or their neighbor or somebody
and it would be they would be providing
a major service because people need
shoes
and so um the worker back then was
connected to their work and work is
extremely important in our well-being
and being able to to contribute to
society
through your work is is really important
i think to being
human and so marx describes this process
of alienation where we're kind of
becoming less human we're becoming alien
because we're separated from our the
products of our labor
and so you can imagine like a mcdonald's
worker or something today
where they they don't have any
relationship
to the food that they that they get
like the the beef and the vegetables
they have nothing to do with with where
that's coming from
and then maybe they're working at a
drive-through and they never
even see the customer they don't see the
customer that they produce the food to
satisfy
and so that's that's really frustrating
internally as a worker
is that you don't get to you don't get
to see the benefit
or the product of your of your labor
sorry that's kind of a side side thing
um that's really important though
because if you're not
uh feeling like you're um
you're directly um part of
the serving of people with what you're
doing
um every day in a helpful flourishing
abundant way and if you're not getting
fractional ownership in that process
you're not gonna
feel healthy happy prosperous
yeah and you mentioned the uber driver
this is a great example
um of of a process that's happened since
world war
ii so before world war ii we had
we had a lot of factories
and we had a national economy and there
was this term called fordism
which is that these these factories
were unionized and they had a very
efficient process
to developing products but since world
war ii
we've seen a globalization of the
economy which has pushed a lot of these
jobs
these manufacturing jobs out of the
country um
and so there's kind of this
decentralized
aspect of of of work today
that really is alienating and so
i think i think uber
um this this term i'm kind of getting at
is called post-fortism
and so we no longer work in unions we we
no longer work in single factories and
there isn't
a national business this business is
international now and we're just kind of
all pieces
we're all kind of working in different
places along the production line in
different countries and
and whatnot um
so i guess that gets me to kind of a
bigger
idea i wanted to cover was this within
capitalism there has been
kind of two phases or even three phases
um so the two phases is that
and each each of these social
socioeconomic systems have have
something like this so there's a
there's a progressive phase and a
reactionary phase
and so the progressive phase is is the
early period
it's the revolutionary phase
and the in the reactionary phase is kind
of
the decaying the system is decaying
and and so and so in the progressive
phase there's people who wanted
capitalism because it because it was an
advancement
beyond feudalism and so we had the
like the jacobins during the
french revolution and the rise of
industrialism
and this was all about kind of defeating
feudalism and building up a new a new
system
which was very revolutionary at the time
but um later on its capitalism
is uh less effective um
there's and we saw the rise of socialism
in the ussr in 1917 and then china in
1949
capitalism has been on this steep
decline and so there's
there's people within well the ruling
class
they want to protect and sustain this
old system and we had the same people
during feudalism there was
royalists and loyalists who
who were reactionary to feudalism that
wanted to keep that old system that old
way of thinking
that were antagonistic to the
revolutionary capitalists who wanted
who wanted uh who wanted
industries and and uh private ownership
instead of
instead of uh nobility ownership
um so there's these two phases and so
right now we're in the reactionary
phase of capitalism and we've been in
that system
i would say everything changed in world
war
ii and part of that part of the
transformation of world war ii
was going from
where each capitalist state had a
national economy to now where
there's an a global economy and so
after world war ii there the uh there
was something called the bretton woods
agreement
which created a
a world system pegged on the us dollar
and was really just petro dollars
because our
our dollar was pretty much linked to
to oil
uh so one of the one of the things i i
want to say so there there's
these three phases as well so i kind of
talked about an early phase
where there is this kind of really
brutal industrialization and that's
that's um that's where marx worked he
that's what he saw was early capitalism
um the
the writer uh charles dickens he talks
about that time period
where there was child labor people
working 14-hour days and
it was horrible but later on as the
productive forces developed there was
enough
enough wealth in society to provide
social programs
um well let me back up with uh early
capitalism it was
it seemed like a free market and so this
free market
there was this increased frequency of of
crisis
and in 1929 we had the really a really
big crisis
which led to the great depression
and so what um what capitalist
economists
developed from the work of maynard
keynes
was this keynesianism theory which is
that the state would intervene
to prevent these crashes
and would also provide social programs
to the workers
one of the reason they had to provide
social programs is that
they were on the other side of the world
they were dealing with the ussr
and so 1917 the ussr came about there
was socialism
and so capitalism needed needed
needed a product that would compete with
socialism because
because there was all these advances
going on
on the other side of the world so so
capitalism
capitalism was also um after the sorry
after the
the great recession there was a huge
surge in communists here in america
and a huge communist movement the
socialist party
got a ton of votes in one of the
elections there and so
there was this
basically the ruling class had two
options they either had to
had to do something to make the workers
happy or they had to take
this complete control of the of the
capitalist system
and so what fdr did was the new deal
which
which um created a welfare state and
social programs this was a class
concession
it was concessions to the working class
to prevent them from
from having a revolution because because
the
there's people asking for fdr's head
they weren't they weren't happy about
about capitalism after the great great
depression um
and so really the way this worked
these class concessions they work to
blunt class consciousness
because if you're kind of being offered
these social programs that
did improve your standard of living you
were less
you were less able to kind of see the
harsh realities of capitalism
so it's like getting a little temporary
um relief for the
for being for for not looking to the
depth
root of the issue at hand
yeah so they're they're buying off a
section of the working class
um giving them a better life so they
didn't have to think about
the the class struggle the the realities
of capital society that was happening
um so the so the ruling class was
i mean they were able to do this because
capitalism was at its peak
and there there was high productivity
we still had a national economy at this
time
but um but these programs they
they were for a section of the working
class mostly white
um they're unionized and so so this
created another kind of conflict between
this wealthy white working class and
and non-white kind of um
non-white working class and so we saw
this emergence of the labor aristocracy
which is a really important term in
marxism
and so this labor aristocracy is
just this this section of the working
class that had a better life than
than others and so they they had really
no interest
in in a communist revolution or a
socialist transition
because their needs were being met but
as we've seen with the decline of
capitalism and the decay of our system
in the face of of china and rising
socialism
is that we've had
the capitalism has turned into what
lenin calls imperialism
or the highest stage of capitalism so
in order to sustain the high levels of
profits that the capitalists
were doing really this keynesianism
these social programs threatened their
class interests and they're making less
profits so they
so they had to go elsewhere to make
those profits and so they went to the
third world
and so what they've been doing is and
with
with most of the cold war is going to
other countries
destroying any kind of social movements
they have
either through coups or manufactured
protests
and if as a last resort wars
to keep these third world countries poor
and so there's a there's a really good
quote by michael prenty in a video
um there's a video out there on youtube
of him saying this but he says that the
third world is not poor
you don't go to poor countries to make
money there are few
there are very few poor countries in
this world most countries are rich
only the people are poor ordinary people
pay the cost of empire
these countries are not underdeveloped
they're over exploited
and so these countries are rich because
they have so many natural resources like
like the congo for example there's a
wealth of resources
in the congo but they've had a
capitalist dictator
and and now capitalist leaders
overseeing and appropriating the wealth
for the ruling class in those countries
rather than rather than a system
a socialist system that would serve the
entire public
and so imperialism is a really key
concept
it's not just wars a lot of people
and early marxists or socialist thinkers
will
will think it's just wars but it's more
than that it's an act
it's an economic system and it's the
decay of capitalism
and so as capitalism continues its
decline
don't they'll need to increasingly
extract money from
from the third world and and so the
tension
the tension is only increased and only
intensified
um as of late and will only intensify
that's
capitalism's only way out is is to
continue
and increasing exploitation
and so um we've seen the decline in the
disintegration of the labor aristocracy
we're moving manufacturing
to the third world and
and they're now bringing imperialism
home
and so and so people's
people are uh
getting more and more exploited wealth
inequalities even higher than
than it's ever been um another
aspect of of this phase
is is neoliberalism which is austerity
politics
and pushing the burden the financial
burden of society increasingly
from the ruling class who used to pay
for a lot of social programs
and pushing that responsibility onto the
public
increasing their taxes slashing the
programs that serve them
because it doesn't serve their interests
like health care there's no interest in
the ruling class
to provide health care and there's no
interest for them to
provide housing or
food and so
and so um yeah there's this major
transformation that's taken place
since uh 1971 that year that's
that was the year that the britain
breton wood system collapsed
and so where
where the u.s economy was pegged on the
dollar
the international community
started to say that this isn't going to
work because
our our debt was increasing we are
increasingly
debt financing the wars and these social
programs
both on the backs of
the rest of the world who had to who had
to
use petro dollars to pay back america
and use only the dollar as the
as the world's reserve currency so 1971
um
a little bit before that like the french
were asking for their gold back
from the united states and so nixon was
basically forced to
to suspend the gold standard in 1971
and
and so the world is no longer pegged on
the dollar there's now this floating
currency or
fiat currency um and so basically we've
just been printing unlimited money since
then
um and that system
again has collapsed in 2008 basically
and is
i think we're going to see another
collapse here soon
which is going to be really destructive
and i
we thought it was gonna come with covid
and that kind of
push it away but there's something else
coming in and the united states
is uh kind of there's
there's a new alternative that's that's
going to emerge
um
yeah i covered a lot of ideas there
yep yep so
this was probably one of the most
insightful
ways of of viewing um the most recent
transition
i like how when you look at it from the
historical materials and perspective you
um
you almost see a full circling happening
where we're kind of shifting back to
a lot of the more indigenous
inclusive stakeholding planetary
infrastructures where everyone has a
share
in the collective success and we're
leveraging technology like
decentralization and fractional
ownership to make
the transition back um to where we're
one with nature and we're one with each
other
um after this the swing into
all of this technology and innovation
and whatnot
and i like also how um it's viewed
especially most recently
as um the transition
away from what looks like the most
um the most perverse incentives um
in the more neo-liberalistic um
globalization
uh imperialism vibe where
there are our fellow brothers and
sisters across all of these countries
billions where they're also rather than
having their basic needs be focused on
being served
there's also an extractive vibe that is
present there as well
and so it's also not only in these
incredible places like
that i've had a lot of prosperity most
recently like the us
but also going into these um countries
where
uh there we can hone in on the basic
need be met we can do the leap frogging
where they don't have to go through the
same style
of the perverse incentives but they can
leapfrog the perverse incentives to the
next generation our
inclusive stakeholding architectures
that was really exciting as well
and
yeah one more one more transformation i
forgot to mention with neoliberalism is
that there's
there was this transformation before
world war ii from an industrial society
and industrial capitalists to now
financial
society and financial capital so another
word for imperial
another word for imperialism is is
finance capital monopoly
or the monopoly of bankers and so today
we have a global elite a banking elite
that is control of the capitalist world
and so
um it's it kind of goes back
i guess to um
like the american revolution and that we
we did the american revolution because
we didn't want
kings overseas ruling us but now we we
have those kings
they're back and their financial
capitalists and
the one percent and they run the world
and that their wealth is increasingly
becoming concentrated
with neoliberalism and
a great example of neoliberalism is
clinton he deregulated the banking
industry with glass-steagall
he deregulated the telecommunications
company
companies now we have this insane media
monopoly
and so as capitalism is in decline
liberalism is collapsing onto itself
and we've seen a lot of antagonistic
elements come out of the ruling class so
with cancel culture today
as an example like the
ruling class which is now centered
around silicon valley
in the tech the tech economy
which is highly highly financialized
same with health care
is uh pushing pushing uh
this culture war
and censoring people and no one wants
that
the working classes knows that this is
not good
we don't we don't want this and so i
think that's another part of
this objective communist movement
something that's forming underneath the
surface
that's another definition of marxism
actually is
is um being able to look beyond surface
appearances
to see to see what's going on and so
that's why i use dialectics um because
it's
you can't just look at the surface and
make conclusions about the world yeah
there's everything has a lot of
nuance and so and there's a dialect
a dialectic relationship always taking
place
and a kind of a struggle between
between two forces
um so understanding that those
underlying forces is really
is really key yeah this is a great way
for people to ask themselves the
question
what is at the root of my experience
because when you ask yourself that
question
your answer is typically awareness
awareness is at the root of your
experience but then you also ask well
what is your awareness bound
to and typically the first answer
if you also recognize that it's
unbounded it's not bound but then it's
also
is bound to your basic needs being met
as in your
your fundamental social contracts
the fundamental architectures the
fundamental fractional ownership the
fundamental decentralization the
fundamental biomimicry
sustainability renewables all the good
stuff that make it so that
your awareness can stay fully liberated
all the time
and your architectures can feed back
into your awakening
is this is exactly the the line of
thinking that we need is people asking
what is at the root beyond the surface
appearances and how do we maximize
our success at the root level
architecturally
so yes
one of the channels i follow is is
infrared
and uh one of his lines is that
that marxist leninist are are looking
beyond the visible spectrum
into the infrared and so
um i think that's a really cool way to
think about about marxism
and uh the way we think
yes cotton what else
what else um here in this next
um section do you feel like is really um
critical
to address
yeah and uh i want to talk about this
this uh concept called bonapartism
where is that on here is that on here
um yeah just go up a little bit
oh there it is okay yeah so
and and by the way do you feel like you
um need to use the restroom are you okay
right now
i'm okay you're okay i'm gonna um just
go use the restroom
very quickly continue speaking about
bonapartism and i will join you back in
uh in just a moment okay
okay okay
so yes um so in the 18th
mirror of louis bonaparte um one of
marx's
most important books he describes what
he calls bonapartism
and bonapartism is is when there's
divisions within the ruling class
and so as i've mentioned capitalism is
indic
is in decay right now and we don't have
a we don't have a keynesian system
in the state to really protect the
economy from crashes
and so what we've seen with 2008 and
and since we've seen an increasing
frequency of crashes
and crisis within capitalism and so
as as these crisis crises and
continue the the ruling class becomes
increasingly divided on how to handle
on how to handle the situation the
situation of a declining economic system
and so and so in uh the 18th premiere
premiere here um he describes bonaparte
who was kind of a strong man and uh
he took control after
[Music]
in france after
after a lot of uh turmoil um but he kind
of um
had measures that served that
the broad masses he kind of had a
populist message but he also
was pretty pretty militaristic um
and so two good examples to think of
bonapartism
is fdr and hitler and uh
what they did exactly so so fdr
again with the rise of the communist
movement
in the 1930s he kind of had two
decisions he could either
take full control of the economy in
in the interests of the ruling class or
he could um provide class concessions to
the workers to kind of blunt class
consciousness and
and um give the workers a few crumbs
and as we know he went with uh the class
concessions he he he introduced the new
deal
um
and uh gave gave workers some breathing
room in the united states
um but also again um blended class
consciousness
on the on the right we saw hitler
and so what he did it wasn't class
concessions he did class control
and so he kind of he was a strong man
who worked in the interests of the
industrial
capitalists in in nazi germany
and and made reforms that were
in their interests um and
and had a kind of full repression
against
against any communists he slaughtered
millions of communists after he
went into power and had a very
repressive state
so there's kind of two routes you can go
and fascism is the most extreme example
of bonapartism
but today that's really what we need to
be kind of
having an open eyes and ears and looking
out for fascism because
or fascism 2.0 or some kind of ill
liberal liberalism
because we don't have the industrial
base
that we did during the world war ii
period to provide
to provide class concessions we don't
have that
we don't have that uh that same type of
economy anymore
and so really all the ruling class can
do to sustain their profits is
is class control measures um so that's
why we've seen a lot of austerity
um the hitler did a lot of austerity
programs as well
um stripped a lot of social programs and
push a lot of the burden on to the
public
um but some other some other bona
partists we can think about
um jfk was kind of a bonapartist he
represented the industrial or not the
industrial the international
finance sector of capitalists which was
kind of a new sector at that time
in the 60s like i said after world war
ii we had this transition from
from a national global economy the
global economy is kind of what
what jfk represented and there's some
some theories that maybe that's why he
was assassinated because he was too good
with them
um and then we had uh nixon who was
often called the last liberal president
um because he was the last keynesian he
was the last guy who
who had social programs he developed
like the the epa
um environmental protection agency and
and he really served one section of
of the ruling class um so today so today
as capitalism is
is facing another crisis
we've seen this division between between
the ruling classes and so that's
i think this is the best way to
understand the divisions between the
republicans and the democrats
is that this isn't a division between
the working class this is a division
between the ruling class
and so biden rep and clinton
and obama what they represent is that is
neoliberalism
is this austerity politics is global
financial
capital monopoly and uh
trump and bernie well trump because he
actually got elected
um really pushed back against this
establishment
um he had protectionists
type of economy he put a lot of tariffs
on china
and that is antagonistic to the
neoliberal
economy which which uh advocates for a
free global market
um so so this idea of false
consciousness
kind of emerges here because
these divisions again they're not
divisions within the working class the
divisions
within the ruling class and so they've
they projected
this division and made a lot of us think
that that's what
we should fight for as well so so
there's
um a lot of people who identify at the
parties
and i again it's important to to to say
that
this country isn't split half and half
as a lot of people will think it's half
of the people didn't vote for biden
and half of the people didn't vote for
trump it's a quarter
a quarter of americans voted for biting
and a quarter of americans
voted for trump and these people may
have been
may have been um kind of influenced by
what marx would call a false
consciousness
or it's the consciousness it's not their
consciousness as workers it's the
consciousness of
the ruling class so it's false it's not
their consciousness
it's the ideology of the ruling class
and so work the working class i think is
is becoming more united and i think that
is one of the tasks of the
class conscious worker of communists
today
is to help workers realize that they're
united
i didn't mention the other half of
americans are the people that didn't
vote
the 150 americans that didn't vote that
realize this
system doesn't work and they don't even
want to vote because it doesn't serve
them
there's a huge untapped potential in
this
in america today to win these people
over
if we win over half of bernie
or a half of biden voters and half of
trump voters
and half of this 150 america 150 million
americans that didn't vote
we could have a viable third party that
could challenge
the neoliberal social order that exists
today
and so it's important today right now as
our task to
to help educate the masses and reach
those people
those 150 million people that
that aren't stupid they they they know
something
very very important
and that the system isn't working for
them
yeah activating the other 150 million
people in the us and even worldwide
people know that
this type of non-inclusive stakeholding
this
exclusive stakeholding is not working
for them
and so it's great to figure out the
ways to activate um their engagement
in building out the decentralized
architectures inclusive stakeholding
activating awakening consciousness all
of that
and by the way cotton as we keep talking
i just want to i just want to reference
rem hit as many of the core
essences as possible as we keep talking
because a lot of this is also um it's
insightful
but it is kind of it can kind of get a
little bit into the weeds and i also
want to stay at like the core essences
as much as possible as we um keep
playing
yeah i did want to just mention one more
thing about bonapartism
so the way that's manifested in the
united states
is that the democrats coming all the way
from the carter era
and beyond they represent more of a soft
power
and the republicans and the neocons
like bush advocate more of a hard power
so there's always been this this rift in
in america
in the mid in the um
military-industrial complex or the
ruling class between
there's been this rift between the cia
and the pentagon so the cia
tends to kind of worked undercover they
work undercover
covertly in other countries to
manufacture these protests and coups
and um i mean they're not they're not
all about war
whereas the hard power the pentagon the
republicans
these neocons will will um
push military intervention and invasions
and so i mean that's where
iraq war came from um and um as
as opposed to um like some of the coups
that the cia did
um i mean there's so many but there
there's
that they're they're trying to do a few
right now like in cuba
cuba right now there's there's these
manufactured protests like cia-backed
biden supporting protests in cuba
um from a very small fraction of
disgruntled cubans um
and they're trying to manufacture this
this unrest in the country
whereas the majority of cubans support
the government
and have been in the streets in the
millions
fighting what the us is trying to do
right now
um but the cia they uh
you just look at libya libya
had a socialist government under gaddafi
they're the most
prosperous country in africa and obama
and hillary went in there and and killed
and assassinated gaddafi
and so that place has just been in ruins
ever since they have opened slave trade
um and they didn't need a full-on
military invasion they
and there was pretty invasive still
sitting in
an assassination but um this just
happens over and over right i made a
whole video
like a two and a half hour video about
about a lot of the
cia crews and military interventions
that that have taken place
yeah so you could check that out if you
want to
learn more about our cous and everything
we've been in every single continent
and almost every single country
really doing bad things
these links are in the bio below by the
way for you guys as
ryan's youtube channel and his uh
twitter
so you guys can check this out
ryan um let's uh
because we have we have a good amount of
this to still cover
um let's let's hone in on sort of the
essence we already covered
um some of this but i feel like this is
still a core
aspect for us to cover and then we have
um
the shift to seeing what is better and
also um talking about the cpi and then
um and then wrapping up with this so
so let's um let's let's
let's continue at the essence of uh
of this so what is what would you say is
there to cover here with the essence
as we go down
well yeah i just wanna like ideology has
been really important for me
to understand and trying to understand
how ideology works because it's
something that's
hard to understand i guess once if
you're in it
and a lot of people don't realize how
intellectual or how
ideological they really are yes um
there's a clip out there
from sliver of jesus
or he says we're always in the trash can
um we're always eating ideology and it's
it's from the trash can like we're
always consuming this ideology
even though we don't realize it um
so it's always there it's always it's
always present
and so one of the
one of the uh tasks of socialism is to
take back control of these institutions
the state law institutions
scientific institutions the military
the police take control of these
or these institutions and create what
what lenin called the dictatorship of
the proletariat well mark said it too
and this this term has been
um troublesome a little bit because it
this is the word dictatorship in it but
what it means is
dictatorship of the proletariat the
working-class masses
the workers are in control rather than
the capitalists so
today we live in the dictatorship of the
bourgeoisie
we live under the dictatorship of the
capitalists
they they are the rulers and they
they produce the ideology
or sustain the ideology that we
that tells us how we think and how we
act what we believe
and so a lot of our lens and how we see
the world
is is um
is distorted through through this
ideology
wow yeah there's a
there's a lot of mimetics that are
spread down there's a lot of memes and
ideas that are spread
downward uh like you were talking about
with false consciousness
and there's a lot of just um this
dictatorship of the like plutocrats
um that are running the entire
planet and that just create
a lot of noise um and create a lot of
of ill will um rather than
um just look at the mainstream news and
see that it's not about people doing
good
things and about maximizing human
potential
but it's all about trying to put one a
group of people against another group of
people
and that is uh the false consciousness
versus
the all the good things that are
happening entrepreneurially
scientifically
revolutionarily across the planet and
how we can
continue um sparking those um those
great
initiatives so i see so there's in that
like bottom-up grassroots awakening is
the people that are awakening is to take
leadership roles
in the main newly designed institutions
to then further create more feedback
loop that's great
yeah so some of the teachings of the
ideology
of liberalism and capitalism is that
one of the things that comes out of that
is that this idea that the west is the
best
or that socialism has always failed
and really what that is mean
really they overlook the fact that
socialism did work
and i mean we can talk about that that
next
um with the ussr in china
is that socialism does work there
um and it's i think it's really
important as
marxists or socialists to realize and
understand that so
that china is socialists um
some people will try to
try to twist marx's words or the
the way they understand marx into
to justify some kind of narrative that
that china is capitalists and
i think once you get deeper into marxism
you realize this is clearly not the case
interesting so you you've termed china
as an advanced marxist
i think understanding china is advanced
marxism
at least it was for me it took me a long
time to even
approach the question of china totally
uh yeah they're fascinating you know i
visited in 2019 right
we talked about that that's really cool
i went for almost a month
yeah that this is this is a really
interesting point about um
yeah let's play with this i i i i'm
i'm interested to see um how this
unfolds together keep playing with this
yeah so first to understand china you
need to understand
what happened in the ussr and so
that's a big topic but um i think
the ussr focused a lot on a lot on a
centralized planned economy
and their main goal is to raise
the productive forces in the country
through a planned economy
and that worked all fine and well um
at least during the stalin era
and it worked it worked in china as well
um during the mao period um but
with with uh world war ii and
the rise of the global economy
it kind of presented a new challenge for
these countries
and so one of the really important
aspects of china was that they were able
to
to kind of pivot and change their
approach
and evolve whereas the ussr was more
rigid
and and uh
had a lot of internal corruption and
wasn't able to really
to really evolve with the changing times
after tens of millions of deaths we do
need to just also address that there was
um a lot of um ridiculous
um uh um
attempt at uh at something that was
um looked at uh
thinking that it would be yeah fantastic
and that there were ten tens of millions
of deaths in that process
and so obviously there's a big learning
that happened from that process but it's
still important to take that
into our calculus yeah
yeah and regarding that there's a huge
amount of nuance
around the ussr and early china and
understanding kind of
what happened there and why i mean these
countries came out of
came out of they were backward countries
feudalist
agrarian societies and they had an in
the greatest explosion in human history
that we've ever seen i mean ussr went
from
this backwards agrarian society to the
space age in a lifetime
50 years like that's that's pretty
amazing to me
and during the mao period life
expectancy doubled
and went it increased 31 years
so people the chinese people may have
seen their grandparents die
at age 30 something now living to age 60
and now today beyond age 75.
um so that's that's definitely one of
the most remarkable accomplishments
of socialism and specifically like china
is that they've been able to to
just dramatically increase the living
standard of the people living there
um so with with mao
i mean he he was there from the
the when the people's republic of china
took over
in 1979 till so was in 1976 i think when
he died
and so he was able to oversee kind of
this centralized plan economy
um and so one of the differences between
the ussr
and china was that the ussr
the proletariat or the industrial
workers
to to do the revolution whereas whereas
china focused more on the peasants
and that was just because they had they
had a different
they're in different historical contexts
and
a different different situation in each
country
but yeah one of the problems with china
and mao
is that they um
there was like the great leap forward
the cultural revolution and the gang of
four
um that happened and
and uh yeah a lot of people died and
it was a mistake um but
really what they're trying to do with
the cultural revolution is
is trying they tried to get rid of class
um and tried to make more people more
equal they moved a lot of
students kind of rich wealthier students
from the cities into the into the
countryside
so they could learn how how the
agrarian workers worked um so they tried
to integrate
society in that way um
so there might have been kind of like
these good ideals behind it but
really the society wasn't ready
for that type of massive change and so
that's where this really important
figure uh deng xiaoping comes into play
is after mao died he was able to take
control he um
he put the gang of four on trial for
their atrocities during the cultural
revolution
um and really responded to
to the new global economic context of
global capitalism
by opening the country up um
by uh reform and opening up um so they
they started to allow
started to allow um kind of free markets
to enter the country and allowed
external investors to enter china and so
that's where the kind of relationship
between china
and in the us started
and so what what deng xiaoping
did was
um he articulated what
what would be socialism with chinese
characteristics
and so one of mao
mao kind of
mao kind of mimicked the ussr's economy
in a sense and that it was centrally
planned and it kind of did the same
thing the ussr did but what
what deng xiaoping did was socialism
with chinese characteristics which was
an attempt to kind of
um have um
have socialism in the context of the
chinese
um in their own specific
the own their the specific problems
within china
to address the specific issues within
china
so one thing that it seems like has
happened since
um since china's like last
decade or so especially of um
advancement materialistically is that
there has been a greater amount of
basic needs that have been met and that
has
in a sense liberated people to be able
to pursue
whatever sort of scientific or
engineering style
of advancement now there are specific
also limitations to that um freedom
simultaneously with
a little bit around the social crediting
system
and um which aims to act as a forcing
function for
morality and ethics which i think is
really also
simultaneously interesting um
but um there is a little bit of
restriction on
um on taoism um and
on spirituality um whereas vast majority
of the
of um spiritual uh ideas
are confucianist but um there
there's still quite a lot of fascinating
um energetic actualization
in china given the
um advancement that has happened
materialistically
um yeah which has been super fascinating
to see
exactly so deng xiaoping
really focused on
marxism and how and how marx says
that we need to develop the productive
forces and create the wealth and
abundance
before we can really do socialism
um and and start and what before you can
start to resolve some of the
contradictions like the class
contradiction in the state contradiction
um you need to create
the wealth and abundance required for
socialism
and so that was their mistake with the
cultural revolution they tried to push
push the ideology ahead of the economic
base
and that created a lot of tension and
they weren't ready for it
and so um deng xiaoping that's what
he realized this is amazing i'm always
blown away by deng xiaoping's
ability to have to be able to step back
say we made mistakes
and and evolve and change and and
and build and do what china's done since
the 1978
when deng xiaoping came into power
um
yeah so i think that's this is a huge
spot where
western leftists and actual marxists
again in disagreement because marxists
like the western leftists think that
socialism is about going backwards to
to um to that primitive communism or
something
um whereas marxism is more about
like they think we all need to um the
western leftists think that we all need
to be
poor that we all need to be
poor but um marxists believe that we
should all be richer
um we should all we should all of course
wealth and abundance to create socialism
and communism
after everyone deserves
a [ __ ] big nice fat slice of the
collective pie enabling their fullest
actualization
yeah absolutely
in harmony with the earth this is
crucial another aspect of socialism with
chinese characteristics is that it
embraces
chinese culture so china has a long
rich history that that civilization has
been there for five thousand years
and with the mao period he cracked down
on religion
and confucianism um
and um what we've seen today with
with xi jinping is that they're
they're reintroducing confucianism and
they're
kind of they're allowing it and um
they're just not
they're not restrictive as much because
they realize that it's it's part of the
history of china
so they're really embracing embracing
the
the culture as opposed to the ussr which
they kind of only considered history the
ussr considered history starting in 1917
when the communists took power they they
kind of
threw out the baby with the bathwater or
whatever um
they didn't care about the past
or they kind of threw it away um because
because it was a dark a dark past you
know with uh the tsarists russia
and and what happened there
so yeah they um china was able to
kind of evolve and embrace embrace their
cultural
their cultural history
and another important point is that deng
xiaoping said they would never do
they would never do what the ussr did to
stalin
what they they would never do that to
mao and so
in the ussr after stalin died khrushchev
gave this famous speech that said stalin
was bad and
and um they just really denounced the
stalin period
whereas china they've kind of taken a
different approach
a dialectical approach and and realized
that mao did make amazing advances
he he helped industrialize
the country and um double the life
expectancy
decreased illiteracy he made a lot of
advancements but he made
a lot of mistakes and the chinese
communist party today
recognizes the cultural revolution and
such
as a mistake and so i think that's
really important to understand
understanding china it's also really
important in
understanding the us in the sense of if
the us
can become more transparent
to its own incredible beneficial
architectures that have enabled
prosperity and then also look at its
pathologies and cancers
and non-inclusive stakeholding and if
we can become really honest with how to
um take what's been working and what's
good and add that with these new ideas
and new architectures
to enable prosperity because the us
right now isn't having a very
transparent discussion
with itself about what is most optimal
exactly and i think a lot of that is
because the us
the ruling class is divided and that
they they don't have a unified
position on how to move forward i mean
there's the neoliberals who want to
usher in the great reset
and and all the
austerity that will come with that and
then there's
another side that wants to so yeah the
the um the neoliberals another
way to understand this is that they
represent the largest
and the largest most concentrated sector
of capital
and usually global capital the
trump represented a different sector of
capitals he represented kind of the
smaller
national capitalists and wanted to
preserve the national economy
versus the neoliberals which advocate
for making money on a global economy
and so there there's this division right
now on how to
how to move forward and how to protect
and save capitalism
which i don't think can be saved it's
just gonna decay
and they're gonna use more class control
measures
to stay in control um
we're seeing what we've seen with china
is proof that socialism works
and that it's superior i mean
you visited i'm sure i'm sure you could
attest to some of this but
they're really advancing way beyond the
ability that
capitalism can at this time and that's
because they have
they have they have socialism they have
they have 95 million
communist party members working
to build socialism in that country
they they're able to make a hundred year
plans
and 50-year plans to get [ __ ] done
unlike the us
and capitalists which focuses on
like five-year budget impact models and
and only does things if there's somebody
profiting if there's a profit to make
china doesn't operate that way i mean
they want to build
they want to build up society um
with they allow people to make profits
um
like huawei and alibaba and all that
they're not against like billionaires
aren't exactly the problem here because
there's chinese billionaires
and when they get out of line the ch
they hear about it from the chinese
communist party
um there's been there's been
billionaires executed by the communist
party people that
they've found out have been exploiting
workers and taking advantage of workers
or whatnot
um so it's it's still important to build
up
the the economic
it's important to do economic
development and
and that's an important aspect of
building socialism but that
that doesn't mean it's it's capitalism
and so a lot of liberals here
in the west make this this fatal
reduction
where they say that capitalism is
markets and socialism is
is a planned economy and that's just
false
um they also try to say that like
like the post office or the fire
department socialism or rhodes
and they they say that that socialism
but
um markets are capitalism and so they
can coexist well that's
that's not true either these are
mutually exclusive terms again they're
it's an entire social order with the
base and superstructure above it
and so in china we don't they don't have
that same base and superstructure they
have
socialism as their economic base and
their ideology is marxism
and so one of xi jinping's projects in
china
has been to kind of revitalize ideology
in china and again they're i think
they're doing that because they realize
that was one of the mistakes
of the ussr the ussr failed at
in their ideology they weren't able to
sustain marxist ideology
through several generations past the
revolution
they didn't really know what they had
they didn't know what they're fighting
for
and so they just they kind of had this
idealistic
starry-eyed vision of the west and
capitalism
which which had a huge huge step ahead i
mean
capitalism is was this was the system in
establishment before they came to power
and they are
they're already at their peak when the
ussr basically came into existence
and so um
there's this big man kind of this big
mistranslation between the east and the
west
and china's been able to
been able to to pivot and kind of kind
of evolve with the changing times
and so one of the biggest goals of the
chinese
communist party has been to
eliminate poverty and so just last year
they they announced that they were able
to eliminate absolute poverty for 90
million people
in that country um so just another
huge achievement of of the communist
party and so like anyone who says that
china is capitalist doesn't really
understand marxism
this is so good it plays
it placed so well into what into what
you were just saying this is the video
that we made
um at the end of our
trip in 2019 and
uh coming back to from doing the
interviews in my mind being blown by the
rich history culture and roaring
economic success
and here you know there's mao
writing there's you know there's the
respect
that's still there um
and you know they're just incredible
technological advancements
and um you know everything is so qr
driven right this is uh um
you know qr code and just payment
without card this is ai facial
recognition for entering
picking university um so
this is what you were talking about a
moment ago which is most people don't
know but this little
um this little visualization
of of chinese companies
is a basically analogous
alibaba tencent huawei baidu
bite dance billy billy uh cena etc
are analogous dji they're analogous to
this
for us um to the google and
and uh and amazon and netflix and
facebook and twitter and tesla
uber microsoft etc and so you don't
actually
notice that um that
and this is the belt and road initiative
which will i wanted to talk about that
yeah i saw that on the list so we'll
talk about the belt and road initiative
but that um you don't actually notice
that um this is from west lake
university the first public private
um research partnership in china
that actually enables um there to be
a
a private interest in what is happening
at the same time as
public um guidance and this is what
their architected campus is
uh looking like that they're going to be
moving into soon
yeah it's it's amazing and so um i just
this was uh this was very profoundly
influential
um and you know when you look at things
like
like uh um like this you know you're
you're really talking about the future
in many ways and you know this is
nothing like what it is portrayed in the
media again you have to have your own
um like brothers and sisters and your
own perspective
in terms of your own relations with
friends that are there and building
connection and family with people
and not just relying on the false
consciousness
media narratives that are being
promulgated so that's a great way
to put it so um we'll also put this
video
in the um in the bio of of the
um conversation with ryan um from our
from our channel
so um let's uh let's continue pulling
this up so we wanted to talk about um
belt and road initiative
bri yeah so
it's important to understand that
china is not imperialist again
imperialism is an economic system
that comes out of the decay of
capitalism
and it seeks to make the world poor it
goes into other countries
exploits their markets for their benefit
for for a wealthy global elite to
profit and keep these countries poor and
under their thumb
and so um these are zero-sum games
imperialism um we go in
the u.s or uh whatever capitalist
countries go into the congo
exploit their resources the congo
congolese people aren't getting any of
that benefit
um and so what china
the amazing progress that china has made
with the belton road initiative
under xi jinping is that they're
actually creating an
alternative to imperialism this global
financial order that's taken hold of the
world
and so what they've done is they created
a network within
100 countries over 100 countries now
they've created this network where
they'll build
infrastructure they they use
the asian investment bank
on and they they they use the bank to
fund these infrastructure projects
to lift the people in those impoverished
countries
so they're more so that they can have
economic development
which is which imperialism has been
holding them back from
um so it's more about developing
locally rather than extracting
yeah and and also creating an
alternative
kind of silk road um to
to circulate products as an alternative
to
so they don't have to go to a to a
western imperialist country
to get whatever resource they need
there's kind of a network
working together and they make these
deals
based on this idea of mutual benefit on
the basis of mutual benefit
um so they're making sure that both both
countries are winning
and there isn't a loser and so normally
imperialism will go to a country
and they'll they'll work with this group
of capitalists or national bourgeoisie
that's in control
and they'll just make that small group
of bourgeoisie rich
at the expense of the masses and uh take
all their
their their natural resources and oil
and whatnot
now with china they're they're creating
alternatives so
so the congo doesn't have to
use western imperialists and they'll
have to use the
they don't have to use the imf or the
world bank to fund their infrastructure
projects
um if they had a socialist government
they would go to china
and ask the asian investment bank to
invest in infrastructure projects
on the basis of this mutual benefit so
there's so many
i have a list kind of of all the
different programs through all these
different countries so
like they're building uh roads railroads
pipelines power plants
gas pipelines they're building huge
bridges
airports like fiber optic networks
they're building huge dams
um the seaports
there's so many things they're building
all across the world i mean if you could
just
google belton road and in some of the
countries that they're working with it's
a long list
and it's it's the imperialists are
shaking in their boots
trust me because because this is a real
challenge to imperialism because now if
you're
if you're a third world country you have
a popular
popular revolution or whatever like they
had in venezuela
you could you don't have to rely on u.s
imperialism to fund your [ __ ]
you can go to china and have a better
deal worked out
and so what we're seeing today is
this rise in the age of multi-polarity
so so back during the cold war there was
kind of this
bipolarity there are two poles communism
and capitalism
and you had to choose one um
after 1991
and the clinton era there was this
unipolar era
and you might even call this kind of
post-modernism
also called capitalist realism
capitalist realism
there's this idea that there's no
alternative to capitalism
there's this guy francis fukiyama who
wrote a book called the end of history
suggesting that his that history isn't
going to evolve anymore
um there isn't going to be a socialism
because socialism failed because of the
ussr fell
or was actually overthrown in a coup um
but that's another thing but with the
rise of china
and the belton road initiative allowing
other countries to rise up i mean have
economic development at a level they've
never seen before
um and there's also
russia which um is interesting so after
the fall of the soviet
union they went through a decade of
humiliation one of the worst
financial disasters economic disasters
the world has seen tons of poverty
a lot of people died um and lots of
austerity
and repression but uh when putin got
into power
who isn't a socialist but he
he did nationalize the oil industry he
re-nationalized it
and uh started using the profits to to
benefit the people and so since 2000
when putin came into power
we've seen a dramatic increase in the
standard of living in russia as well
and so there's there's this multi-polar
world emerging
where the u.s isn't the sole superpower
anymore it can't just push around other
countries like it used to
there's there is now a check on their
power
and that's not just one country checking
them like the ussr
with their with their arms race i mean
that's what that was about it was a
check on the us's power
now there is multiple countries and
they're all kind of rising up against
the us
and their imperialism there was just a
vote in the u.n about a month and a half
ago
about about whether
whether it was okay for the us to impose
sanctions on cuba
well um however many uh
there was only three countries that
voted in line with the us
or two countries that voted with the us
three countries that abstained
and 150 or 160 or 180 i can't remember
the number
180 countries oppose the u.s sanctions
on cuba
which have been in place for like 30
years now just
disgusting because sanctions kill they
prevent
food and medicine from entering the
country
they hurt the most vulnerable people of
those countries
and they're and they're done to to hurt
these
these uh countries that challenge
western imperialism
and so the world is starting to stand up
against
against u.s imperialism and the us
dollar
is is gonna is really facing
some precarious times and like i said
earlier we're
we're heading towards some kind of major
crash and it's gonna be devastating
and that's going to bring about a lot of
oh it's going to bring the class
struggle to the forefront and
i don't know we're going to see
something well we already see it with
the 2008 deployment of peer-to-peer
digital exchange and it was happening
right at the same time that lehman
brothers collapsed and so now you have
these decentralized
technologies that are emerging at the
same time as the
monetary disasters happened and so yeah
so we'll
we'll see the continuation of that as
one of the core
um components why don't we talk about
cpi
now center for political innovation and
um we have that up right here as well
four-point plan by the way this is right
here
we you just talked about putin
public ownership of natural resources
also we just had andy bittner on the
show who
has a fractional ownership of renewable
energy generation in the united states
as well
we just talked about decentralization of
banking right here
um mass mobilization rebuilding the
country
uh economic bill of rights so it's great
yeah so i have a little summary i wrote
up about the
about the center for political
innovation i'll just read it off here
it should be going up on the website
soon but it hasn't yet
the website just went up within a few
weeks so
cool we just redid it um we're getting
it going so it's kind of in its early
phase it's not
it's not all the way done but we're
still working on it um so
the center for political innovation is
an educational think tank
dedicated to educating and fostering
visions for a
future beyond capitalism cpi is a
working-class organization of scientific
socialists
and 21st century socialists who study
the history and experience of past
and existing socialist societies and
applied their lessons to our current
material conditions here in america
to develop a new revolutionary program
to solve
the problems facing society marxism and
class analysis enable us to look beyond
surface level appearances
to develop a scientific understanding of
our current material conditions
and propose innovative solutions for
society that serve public need rather
than profits
at the expense of the many we understand
that capitalism can no longer meet the
needs of the american people
therefore we believe being a patriot
today
means to embrace socialism what we call
socialism with american characteristics
we uphold the rich revolutionary
tradition of the american people
in defeating british colonialism
overthrowing slavery
and working-class victories against
racism and jim crow segregation
the cpi opposes racism sexism in all
forms of oppression
we recognize our historical mission to
oppose imperialism
the global neoliberal economic system of
monopoly finance capital
that keeps workers here and abroad poor
there is an urgent need in america to
restructure the left
around a new vision in contrast to the
woke synthetic left tendencies that
advocate destruction
violence and culture wars the cpi
promotes the city-building tendency
of social welfare of social wealth
and abundance required to build
socialism and rescue america
to accomplish this to accomplish this
vision
we propose a government of action to
fight for working-class families
with this revolutionary program we the
people will once again be able to
realize the ideals
of liberty and equality that america was
founded on
and so with that um the center for
political innovation has proposed
a four point a four-point plan
so we we have a vision for what
socialism will look like in america
so the first one is the massive
infrastructure reconstruction
building roads high-speed rail energy
wi-fi irrigation building schools
and having five-year plans to develop
the
the economic the uh
to develop the means of production the
the second point is public ownership of
energy and natural resources
so um taking control of the oil industry
natural gas coal timber
and using those profits not not so
a few rich people can get profits
not so few rich people get more rich but
to
use the profits in a way that serves the
masses maybe that's how we could pay for
all the infrastructure programs we want
to do
also part of this program is developing
nuclear energy
which would free us from from
not only needing oil for energy but also
deal with the climate crisis i'll talk
about that a little bit more
and uh the third point is public control
of banking
so using credit strategically assigned
by the state
in the interests of the country
instead of having a private central bank
like we have today
with the federal reserve um which does a
lot of things
they're not very transparent about how
they use the profits
um the third or the fourth
point is the economic bill of rights and
so this was
this was the idea or program proposed by
fdr
that never never went through um
but it's it's basically just social
programs so a job guarantee or
to deal with unemployment housing
education and health care
so those are the four points that would
that would
help us transition to a socialist
society
so in addition to that we have a couple
couple policy policy proposal solutions
regarding climate change and the energy
crisis
we're proposing that we build fusion
city now
so um
our idea is that we would build build a
new
city in the heartland of america where
we hire
all the world's best best scientists to
work on developing nuclear fusion
and nuclear fusion energy so we can free
ourselves from oil
and stop polluting the planet and that
is the solution to climate change
one of the problems the left gets into
the
western leftists get into is
that they have this malthusian mindset
and ideas about about the about the
environment they blame things like
overpopulation
well that's just a ridiculous myth
actually
what overpopulation isn't the problem
it's
we have all the resources already to
deal with this
these problems the the solution
is is economic development
and building building fusion energy
which would be an actual alternative
um so this would bring a flow of
a flow of jobs into the midwest and the
rural areas that are
traditionally have been kind of left
behind
um you'd create lots of economic
development
and it could also maybe we're still
working out the details of this vision
but it maybe
could be like a uh a hub for the
for the um high-speed rail network
that we would build the the second pro
the second policy proposal that we're
trying to articulate
is how to deal with the immigration
crisis at the border
and so the reason that has
the reason there is an immigration
crisis is because of neoliberalism
because of the destruction of social
programs
to to filter up to the richest national
bourgeoisie in latin america
nafta ruined ruined mexico
and like honduras and guatemala
have just been when they had
a socialist movement it was it was cut
down
and um and so that
latin america hasn't been able to have
economic development because
imperialism has been keeping them poor
the solution is to build
the sandino zapata economic corridor to
build infrastructure
through latin america and
having economic development projects
that will
actually develop those countries in a
way
that's that's not imperialism that would
actually
lift up those people economically
um so the solution and okay so the
sandino
is a is a famous revolutionary from
nicaragua who kind of um
inspired the the socialist revolution
that occurred there in the 70s
and zapata was a famous revolutionary in
mexico
and so it's kind of named after those
two characters
but it's all about economic development
through latin america building a rail
line and
economic hubs to
kind of like the belt and road in
america
yeah exactly that's what we need is is
an american belton road
or we could even get on the belton road
with china
we should be working with china one and
biden the way he talks is that
he wants to he sees china as a threat he
wants to fight them
he wants to beat them in the 21st
century or whatever we're not saying
same thing with americans in general
there's this
vibration that is um
non-uh cooperative and
it's totally promulgated by mass media
hysteria
and it has nothing to do with our
friendship um
with friends and families across um
the multi-thousand-year cultural lineage
that is china
and india and asia in general
and our brothers and sisters in africa
and europe and the middle east
and latin america and south america is
[ __ ] work together as a planet with
everyone maximizing everyone's potential
and enough of the mass media hypocrisy
pinning people against each other
and this is where all of the
decentralization of not only
banking but also of energy with
fractional
ownership of stocks fractional ownership
of energy renewable clean energy
um massive infrastructure renovation
and i love uh what the cpi
has in their four-point plan and i
also uh love how in doing these
architectural
upgrades it enables the awakening of
consciousness from its contracted
energies and lenses of perception to
more self-actualized and self-realized
states it's beautiful it's it's a man
it's necessary for planetary prosperity
exactly so one of our one of our famous
slogans
um is that we need a government of
action to fight for working families
we need a government of action to fight
for working families
the government we have now is not a
government of action they're doing what
they need to do
to sustain their own capitalist class
and their profits for the
global elite they're not working in the
interests of the people why don't we
have health care
this system is just decaying dying
system
it's it's such a problem it needs to be
fixed
but it's never going to get fixed
because there's no profit incentive
in place and there can't be profit
incentives with the way capitalism
is at the crosshairs it's at today
so really what what this four point plan
is
is it's a vision for an alternative
america a socialist
america it's something that
we can look at these points and and
visualize
what what we could achieve we could have
massive infrastructure why do we have
crumbling roads today
why don't we have high-speed rail all
these obvious things
we could actually have these if we had
if we had a real socialist movement a
large massive
popular movement fighting and advocating
for these
these positions yeah it's
the radical decentralization
and universalization of planetary
prosperity for
all humans and all species and
it's beautiful and i i love it
i love it it's that i
they're the amount of baggage associated
with words
like capitalism and communism
and socialism and individualism and
collectivism
there's so much baggage associated with
those words but what is
fresh and what is clean and what is
new is uh decentralization
universalization um planetary prosperity
awakening and architectures and those
are like new
fresh clean words and
um they speak to what we
so deeply in our hearts know is possible
and
it's so exciting that we're
figuring out how to implement that and
how to awaken to that and
do you feel like we're um we're also
ready to wrap with these
um the marxist myths and
misunderstandings as well
yeah we can talk about some of those
um i'm gonna use the bathroom but you
kick us off with this again do you need
to use the bathroom are you good
i'm okay okay all right kick us off with
this i'll be right back
yeah so there's there's a lot of marxist
myths and misunderstandings
um
i think where some of this comes is that
in the west we're stuck in this
liberal angle in liberal anglo box
and so we tend to impose
our liberal ideology into what we
believe
is democracy or freedom we tend to oppo
we tend to impose that idea
in how we think about other countries
and this is a huge mistake
um because the historical context
is a lot different here versus
a socialist or anti-imperialist country
and so one of the big mistakes that
western leftists tend to do is that they
hate they hate
actually existing socialist countries
and anti-imperialist countries
and they see them as non-democratic or
they lack freedom
and they they say things like china's
capitalists that were imperialists
but understanding that this
idea that they're up against a huge
mountain of imperialism this huge
fight world global financial social
order
they have these these states have to
evolve in the way they uh they oppose
they oppose imperialism so one of the
teachings of lenin from
the experiment that happened with the
paris commune is that we need a strong
state
and this is really important to not only
prevent counter-revolution that could
happen internally but prevent
invasions from outside from the western
imperialists
and so in the ussr after
after they had the russian revolution in
1918 in october
they were invaded by 15
imperialist countries and they had a
civil war
with with the people who were advocating
capitalism
and they had a famine they had all these
huge problems that they needed
a strong state to deal with and so
that's why a lot of these repressive
measures
were introduced and that's why the
socialist
states have to be somewhat repressive
in because that they're
they need to protect the revolution um
and so the paris commune was where the
communists took over
but they didn't take control of the
state institutions
and so they were quickly it was quickly
dissolved within about a month i i
believe
um because they didn't have a strong
state to protect
the revolution it just just
got destroyed um so there's this need
for a strong state or what
lenin called the dictatorship of the
proletariat
and that's why these these countries are
more authoritarian
or they seem that way that's a word that
we really need to avoid
as as uh marxist i believe because it's
kind of
only used by the west in in criticizing
and criticizing socialist countries they
call them authoritarian
and and both both state societies are
are highly authoritarian um
there's a strong class rule in america
they control the state and they use it
to to bomb other countries
and to impose austerity across the
against the people
there's a strong state but a weak
government we don't have a government
of action the government doesn't serve
us
it doesn't serve the people um so i
think that's this one
big confusion and there's kind of these
new age
leftists that you'll see they'll call
themselves libertarian socialists
or even anarchists or people who
advocate kind of this co-op
society um that could coexist
with that could have socialism
coexisting with capitalism
um some of these people try to say that
socialism is when you get together with
your friends and
make a pencil factory um this
isn't this isn't socialism none of this
stuff is it's
taking socialism is when you
take control of the major centers of the
economy
and use the profits to serve the public
need rather than
just a few so it's taking control of the
state machinery
and the major sectors of the economy to
serve the people
and so marxism is the city building
tendency
it's an optimistic outlook and that's
that's in contrast to this woke
synthetic left that's emerged
who advocates destruction and violence
and primitivism they advocate for a
violent overthrow
marxists advocate for a peaceful
transition to socialism
a lot of these leftists advocate left
adventurism
which is um and one example is antifa
going around destroying communities and
and causing and bringing violence
in attempt to uh change the system or
whatever
in the 60s there is the the weathermen
or the students for uh
students for democracy here
sds and and they were
they advocated violence um
and so and destruction and that's
around the sorry about the noise
um around the environment again they
have this overpopulation idea they think
that we needed to
destroy society so everyone's poor
that's not marxism marxism is about
making everyone wealthy
building everyone up so we have the
social wealth and abundance
to create to create and build
socialism and eventually reach the
higher stages of socialism
or also called communism which would be
a stateless classless moneyless society
where we don't need a strong state
where we don't have this division of
classes in society
we can use socialism as a transition
from capitalism to communism
to eliminate those contradictions
to resolve those contradictions and
eventually create a stateless society
but it's a it's a
kind of a a
very far out vision um
and we don't know what communism will
look like
that's that's a way in the future
um so so some terms that are used
to describe this group um western
leftists
the chinese have a term called baizu
which refers to western leftists um
i think they're utopian there's they're
often called
ultras which is short
just for ultra leftists
also lennon has a book called
left-wing communism in infantile
disorder
where he polemicizes against this
tendency
um
and so one of the problems that this
this left tendency in addition to the
violence and destruction
they push identity politics
and critical race theory they're the
social justice warriors
they po they promote post-modern
ideology
um a new definition that i've heard
of post-modernism is this rejection
of grand narratives it's a rejection of
ideology
um and so
that's their problem is that they're
they they don't believe in ideology and
they
they kind of reduce the conflicts in
society
in a way that is devoid of class
analysis
in a way that elevates race or
gender or
like trans issues to the surface without
understanding the class dynamics that
gave rise to those
to those struggles and so
really they're missing a class analysis
and an understanding of imperialism and
economics
and ultimately figures like
that are within sphere they end up being
very anti-communist um one of the main
figures is noam chomsky
noam chomsky has a lot of bad things to
say about the ussr
and when what are his motives for
criticizing the ussr
that's another thing we have to ask
ourselves when these
western leftists start going on about
how bad china is
or or syria or russia
we need to ask themselves whose
interests does it serve by them
criticizing
what they're doing they're trying to
build socialism in their country
um what
what's the role of a western leftist to
tell
to tell these lifelong marxists that are
working in their countries to develop
social
why is it their role to tell them what
to what to do
and what's best for their people um so i
think we need to kind of step back as
western leftists
and and we can
critically support these countries but
but it's i think it's it's a we get into
some trouble when we
when we when when we start
imposing our liberal ideas of democracy
and freedom onto china
and saying they're not free because of
free speech
or whatever
so yeah so another problem with these
utopian synthetic woke leftists is they
hate
america they hate the us flag they hate
american culture
and they see regular americans regular
working class americans
as the enemy as the problem so
they they call trumpers fascists and
this is a mistake
they're not fascists they and they're
not they're not white supremacists
either
yeah there's problems with trump and his
rhetoric and everything but
really what these people represent is
that they
are upset with the social order of
things
and they they want an alternative way
out and trump just so happens to be one
of the few people
uh articulating an anti-establishment
message
and they're also kind of fighting this
culture war that's being
pushed by this fake left
there's also elements of the cia kind of
funding in developing this fake left
tendency
in the united states you can uh research
the congress for cultural freedom
and um the partisan review and some of
the influences that the cia has had in
developing
this class this
this tendency that's devoid of class
analysis
so one of the conclusions of this
tendency is that they
they conclude that the american or the
white working class is non-revolutionary
that they're that we have no
revolutionary potential
and that revolution can't happen in in
america because it's the
core it's the the heart of imperialism
and we have a labor aristocracy that we
benefit from
imperialism but what they don't
understand is that that's been
like neoliberalism has destroyed the the
labor aristocracy
what we had is as being is being
dissolved um and so
working class americans know this and
they are
fight they want to fight this and so
there's a movement happening
underneath the surface underneath the
liberal
the liberal surface level
like what the media is telling us is
what's happening
or something deeper happening
and i think we would call that communism
and that's kind of a new kind of a new
learning that i've had recently and
understanding what is communism it's a
movement it's a movement against those
against the social order of things
so i think i covered most of the most of
the things here
yep and then we can
also visit some of these
recommendations and books for people
on the way out you mentioned infrared
already you mentioned the
center for political innovation um yeah
so
in the center for political innovation
um we uh published this
this manual that has um
a lot of text from caleb maupin but also
lenin mao and some some american
progressives and revolutionaries as well
that we've we've created to kind of
use for study groups and to help educate
help use as a tool to help educate the
masses
so you can check check out check this
book out and some of the other
some of the other books that we've
produced um
we also do web conferences we used to do
them every month but now we're they're
about
every other month um just because we
started to do live events
because covet is finally done that's why
i'm going to
la at the end of august we're going to
have a conference
somewhere down there and we're starting
to
to organize locally
and and um
actually reach reach the masses so one
of the problems with
with um marxist groups in the past is
that they're
kind of stuck in the movement kind of
stuck in their own
politics of their own party and we have
a bunch of communist parties
marxist leninist parties in america but
they're not
they're not educating the public and so
they're kind of
they're kind of ahead in in um
they're kind of too far ahead in that we
need a we don't have a
a populist socialist movement quite yet
for us to build a party upon and so
that's what we're focused on is is
really educating the masses and so
we're gonna start going out into the
public and um
start talking to actual real-life people
about socialism and in our vision
for for a different for a different
socialist america
um so i would really recommend
checking out caleb malpin's content he
has a youtube channel
and i found him in like late
october november last year um but
since then i've been i've learned a ton
from this guy
so i couldn't recommend him anymore he
he wrote this book
city builders and vandals in our age
um getting rich without capitalism
um and recently he wrote a polemic
against the synthetic woke left
or this online phenomena called bread
tube
called bread tube serves imperialism
which has gotten a lot of interest
online it kind of exposes
exposes these fake synthetic leftists
that are really controlling the
narrative of what socialism and their
they're the ones defining socialism more
people
more people are using youtube today to
learn about socialism
then then are involved in the marxist
leninist parties and such
and so it was an important task
today to kind of challenge this this
fake narrative and kind of expose them
for what they are
um another another guy i've learned from
a lot recently is infrared which is a
led by haas but it's a collective of
of communists and marxist londoness
and uh they're mostly on twitch
they stream on twitch and um he has a
lot more focus on philosophy
and i'm still learning a lot from this
guy
um but having the philosophical
understanding of marxism
it goes really really deep and um
he's trying to create kind of a a new
a new brand to kind of reorientate the
left as well and kind of
get us out of the problems that we've
been in
another another guy i'd recommend is
jackson henkel
he has another stream that he does a few
times a week
that's pretty good he talks about a lot
of news and he's
had a pretty intense political
transformation as well
um becoming a marxist londonist just
recently
um i would also recommend jimmy dore
glenn greenwald aaron mate
um they've all they're more progressive
i would say but they're
they're on the they're on the right side
of being being progressive and that they
they they really understand the struggle
of the working class they understand
they understand imperialism and the wars
and the problems with neoliberalism
and it was really jimmy dore who got me
who
who helped me become radicalized and to
become a leftist
and and started seeking out marxist
literature
and whatnot
so i would highly recommend caleb malpin
and fred
jimmy dore all those guys um
yeah so i also have some books on on the
list
there's so many good books but uh yeah
just um
read a bunch of marx and lenin the
manifesto i recommend that
this this is probably the most concise
understanding of of communism
um it
it just goes through the whole project
of what what marx is trying to do in a
really con
concise quick and easy to understand way
i think it was the first book that i
really read
that was that was my marks and really
got me started on this whole journey
um critique of the gotha program i would
also highly recommend
um so the gotha program was this kind of
the social democrat welfare state
program advocated by germany
the german social democrats in the 1980
in the 1800s late 1800s and mark showed
a whole critique on how
they were kind of misreading marxism and
that
they were they weren't really yeah they
weren't really practicing
marxism and their program wasn't
socialist so
this is a really good polemic to
understand the pitfalls that
the left makes
lenin's state and revolution is a must
this is a really essential text for
understanding
for understanding the role of the state
and understanding the dictatorship of
the proletariat
both lenin and mao were
had a really
powerful in the way they're able to
distill marxism down into a way that
regular working-class people could
understand
and so understanding or reading mark um
reading lenin and mao is a really good
way to
to kind of get a a concise
understanding because sometimes it's
hard to read marx's old texts and
marks and angles because it's from the
1800s
it's it's it's just sometimes it's a
little too old to understand
um so yeah
mao mao's book here on contradiction
is and on practice are really good it's
all
all about explaining dialectics in a way
that regular working-class people can
understand
he has a an um
he has a pamphlet in here called combat
liberalism
which which is really good in in
fighting
the ideology that that we have to fight
as communists
um lenin has a really good pamphlet
called the letter to
america letter to american workers which
i'd also highly recommend
where he he he writes a letter to the
american workers
in 1918 right after like right in the
midst of their civil war
and in the 15 countries invading
the soviet russia one of which was the
united states
and um really ex making articulating the
idea that
that we're all we're all in this
together against imperialism
and um really trying to um
reach the working class in america and
explain how imperialism
is is hurting it's hurting not only
the russians but it's it's hurting
american people as well
it's a it's a really powerful text
uh also i would like to recommend
michael parente
um this i'm actually just about to
finish
my next video it's gonna be a book
review
about this book which is really it
really well done it was written in 19
1997 and so he's
he's one of the most contemporary
marxist leninist writers
that we can learn from he's written a
lot of really good books
uh another one was against empire which
i used a lot of quotes from in my last
video on imperialism but this book is
really essential because it
it um kind of um he explains how
he explains the the mistake that many
leftists get into where they
they equate fascism with communism it
explains that
fascism there was actual economic and
class interests
and there was a rational reason why
fascism emerged
and that it's completely different from
what
how communists thought about
how how communists did things and the
programs they offered and the kind of
class nature of those societies is very
different
um
let's see
this oh here's the letter to american
workers
this book capitalist realism covers a
lot of
modern topics as well um
this was written in 2009 um so it
talks a lot about post-modernism and
kind of the
this uh really toxic ideology that
we've taken on
in in the west and capitalist realism as
he defines is there is no alternative
this idea that that um
socialism has always failed and that
it's easier to
imagine the end of the world than than
to imagine the end of capitalism
and so on that note um
xi jinping would recommend kind of
reading his work or
just checking out his speech he gave an
hour speech
just last month or earlier this month
not long ago um at the at the
chinese at the communist party of
china's
100 year centenary
so it's 100 years since the formation of
the communist party
in 1921 he gave him a really amazing
speech where he
he articulated the socialist project of
china
and highlighted a lot of their
achievements and
kind of put forth what their program is
going to be for what their program is
going to be like in the future
and right now it's really important for
us to understand china
understand what they're doing because
china is the future like you said china
is
is on a on a trajectory to surpass the
us and almost every metric
um it's really important that we
understand china and what they're doing
and
how we can apply lessons from china to
america
in developing socialism with american
characteristics
socialism applied to the material con
conditions of america
just like how deng xiaoping and xi
jinping were able to do in china
we should be doing something similar
here in america
yeah i would also just like to again
recommend checking out caleb maupin's
work
um he does live streams
several times a week for an hour two
hours he'll
answer any question you have he's like
he's a walking encyclopedia this guy's
been studying
marxism for like 15 years
he's the best resource out there in
america at least
definitely recommend looking into his
work
nice nice
so that's a breakdown of
these
very
essence of mark's
class analysis class consciousness
the perverse incentives across our
existing industries and how to
flip them towards fractional ownership
seeing the
dialectical and historical materialism
and how
materialism and consciousness feed back
into each other
and seeing how we're transitioning into
a
greater scale global awakening uh
in those architectures the
decentralization and the
universalization
of our next um fractional
ownership that maximizes human potential
and how to
see what are the next best
steps in our planetary
actualization of maximal potential with
creating
more and more fractional ownership
and decentralization and
universalization around
public control of energy natural
resources infrastructure
decentralized universalized banking
and some recommendations for a deeper
investigation into this and
it really feels good it feels good to
have
been able to play with you ryan on all
of this so
thanks again for coming on to the show
yeah absolutely thanks for thanks for
bringing me on and i
hope this was informative and helpful
for your audience
um it's it's taken me a while to
come to the level where i've been able
to articulate these ideas
so i think you you kind of hit me at an
important time where
where i finally i think become to come
to a
understanding of uh what i believe is
the right politics
um
like i like i said before um being a
patriot today
loving your country and your community
is
means to be a socialist today and so
and so um
we need to throw out the bad ideas of
liberalism
and capitalism start seeing the reality
of our world
and push for push for
a new revolutionary program that serves
the needs of the people
beautiful and i love how there's
this little big uh planetary excitement
around decentralization universalization
awakening consciousness around
fractional ownership around
maximizing individual and collective
prosperity it's
really exciting and it's definitely the
next step is biomimicking
fungal networks biomimicking the way
that
the the archetypes of decentralized
um things have emerged like the internet
and like cryptocurrencies and so it's
really exciting to bring that more into
our social contract and leverage science
and engineering
and spiritual awakening in that process
so
it's really exciting it's a great time
for this and
uh thank you again for coming on and
yeah it's been great it's been great
and thanks everyone for tuning in you
guys can
find the links in the bio below to
ryan's youtube channel as well as
twitter and also cpi as well the link is
down there in the bio check it out
and their four point plan
and
that is that is all thanks again yeah
thanks for tuning in we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below like
the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
share the video with other people that
you feel like this could be an
interesting way for them to perceive
um the the interplay between
consciousness awakening and materialism
and basic needs being met
and decentralization universalization
etc
and that is that is
all thank you again cotton good to talk
to you
thank you yeah hopefully i'll
see you again on another stream we'll
see
yes exactly i'm gonna wrap this stream
we'll stay in the studio
here so just hold tight thanks everyone
talk to you soon
bye